Good morning, everyone. Thank you for coming bright and early.
Time for us to get started. So I'm Paul Michiel.
I've had the privilege this year of being the program chair
for this annual meeting and to do that with Dr.
Alice Shaw and to work with a marvelous AACR
team in putting together this program.
This session that we're talking about today is on extrachromosomal DNA,
and I want to draw a few parallels, if I might.
So I'm going to give an opening talk to set the table
to the field and what's happening with regard to biological
insight and where it's going. We're then going to hear
from the HDSI Chancellor's
Professor,
Dr. Vineet Bafna from UCSD, who's going to be talking about
tools and how we capacitate research across the field.
And then we're going to hear from Professor Mahim Jamal Hanjani, who's been a true
pioneer as a lung oncologist who goes all the way from
mechanism to studying patients. And the topic is all going to be around
extrachromosomal DNA. There's a tagline for this
year's meeting that has to do with
precision about the science of medicine.
Purpose, to have our science go all the way to saving patients'
lives. Partnership, because this can only be done together.
And to save lives, advancing science to save lives
globally. I'd like to hope and think that the field of
ecDNA exemplifies that kind of teamwork.
When we started this work back when it was first
published in 2014, if you were to have an ecDNA interest
group,
it would be about three people in the room.
And now it's become one of the most important topics in the field of cancer,
and that's really because of you. There's a culture to this
ecDNA field that's allowing it to move rapidly.
It's a highly inclusive, highly collaborative culture where we
encourage and want people to come into the field to lower the barriers for
entry to research. And the only requirement is to pay
it forward, to share your data as you move forward.
So please keep that in mind. We are here, we are open, and we're looking
forward to having new collaborators in the field.
So without further ado, I'm going to launch into my talk.
So
when we think about genes and how they're inherited,
we think about these,
chromosomes.
So
they're the physical unit
of genetic information inheritance.
They're how information is passed from parents to children or from cell to
cell during division.
Everything we know about human genetics stems from our
understanding of chromosomes. They set the
rules from how cancers form to how cancers evolve.
And in fact, when we think about precision oncology, they're the basis of
it. With the mapping of the human genome
and the availability of next generation sequencing, we can
map these lesions and identify what's gone wrong with each individual
patient's cancer and tailor therapies for it.
However, the problem is that the effectiveness is
very incomplete. For many patients, these methods haven't
helped patients. And part of the reason is what isn't
in this picture, and that's these extrachromosomal
DNA particles that have been hiding in the nucleus in plain sight.
This morning, I'm going to tell you about a historical context to this
field, where the field is going, share some biological
research and its implications, and foreshadow the
future before I turn it over to my colleagues.
So this work really started back in about
2013, and it started with a graduate student in my lab named David
Nathanson, who's now a professor at UCLA.
And we were struck by something. We were studying glioblastoma that
has a very high frequency of EGF receptor amplifications.
It should have been the poster child for EGF receptor targeted therapy, and
yet it wasn't. The patients didn't respond.
And there were lots of reasons that were given, and one of them was this massive
amount of heterogeneity, how one cell could vary from another.
Going all the way back to 1976, Peter Nowell had put forward this
clonal evolution hypothesis that cells may differ
in their DNA and that when you treat, you are going to
select for the cells that are most resistant, and it should change over time, and
if you were to remove the drug, it should change back.
And we deployed single-cell technologies to look at this, and in fact, the
tumors changed,
but they didn't do it at the rate that we expected.
It was lightning fast, and that made no sense by classical
genetics. Even more strangely, look at this
schematic for a moment. Let's just say red here means you have a lot of the EGF
receptor oncogene amplified, and yellow means you have very little.
If you were to take a yellow cell and put it into a dish or a mouse, you'd
expect to get a, quote, "yellow tumor," or one with low EGF receptor
amplification. If you took a red, you should get a red tumor with
high amplification, but that's not what happened.
Every single cell gave rise to the same original tumor
with this full spectrum heterogeneity, and there was simply no way to explain that
by classical genetics. So we basically
looked because we realized you can't actually tell where a piece of DNA is
inside the nucleus of a cancer cell during interphase.
The only time you can tell is when the chromosomes line up.
And that's what we did here, and it was quite illuminating.
The blue here, this is a glioblastoma sample from a patient, and the blue
are the chromosomes stained with DAPI.
The red is the EGF receptor oncogene, and the green is the chromosome 7
centromere probe. It's supposed to be on chromosome 7.
You're supposed to have two copies. Here you have close to 100.
And noticeThat almost none of it is on chromosomes.
And then you treat with an EGF receptor tyrosine kinase inhibitor, and the DNA
almost completely disappears. And then you remove the drug, and it very
quickly reappears. Now, that statement should shock you.
You're treating with a tyrosine kinase inhibitor, and the DNA is almost
disappearing, and you remove the drug, and it's reappearing.
We published in "Science" in 2014 to essentially
a colossal scratching of heads.
And I remember talking with people about it, and they would say,
"The oncogene I study, c-Myc, it's on chromosome eight,"
and I'd say, "When it's amplified." And say, "How do you know?" And they'd pull out
a TCGA map. And I remember thinking of Ptolemy's map of the solar
system. Maybe the sequencing measurements were absolutely right, but the
map was wrong. And so at that point, I started working with
Vineet Vafna, who's speaking after me,
because Vineet also had the same suspicion.
And what we did in a paper that was spearheaded by Kristin Turner at the time, a
postdoc in the lab, was to ask, where are genes actually amplified?
And we did it by integrating sequencing and the technology that allows
us to ask does this amplification arise as a circle
and looking during metaphases. And the results were crystal clear,
as you can see in these pictures. All of these driver oncogenes, when they're
amplified, are frequently amplified on extrachromosomal DNA
particles. So we published that, and people began to pay attention.
And have a look at these scanning electron micrographs.
There they are in front of your eyes, bagels, donuts, SpaghettiOs,
whatever you want to call them. These circular DNA particles that have been hiding
in plain sight in the nucleus of cancer cells.
And since then, we've learned a lot about them.
We've learned that they're large, frequently between a million and five million
base pairs.
We know that they're chromatinized, that is, they're wound around these
nucleosomes' histone cores but not exactly in the
same way as normal chromosomal DNA. It's much more accessible.
The chromatin is like an accordion.
It opens and closes to allow or exclude the transcriptional
machinery. On ecDNA, it's always open and accessible and
transcribing. We've learned that they are not found in normal
tissues and that they occur through at least two
mechanisms, through the double-strand breaks and through
chromothripsis, which I'll mention both.
So one of the questions that came up is, why did you see this when
other people hadn't? And the answer is actually other people had.
And I'll talk about that, but there was more to the story than that, and it
had to do with how we look. In the old days, cancer biologists
would interrogate cancer cells by looking at tumor cells under a
microscope. And what they had then was fantastic spatial
resolution when they would make metaphases of tumor cells, but very
little genome resolution, and the technology's changed.
They moved from fish probes to microarrays, and then
there's the mapping of the human genome and next-generation sequencing
technologies.
But you realize when we're doing that, we have fantastic genome
resolution now, but the spatial resolution is an inference because what we're
doing is we're mapping short reads back to the reference genome,
but the reference genome comes from normal cells, and there's an implicit
assumption that things are in cancer cells where they are in normal cells, and
that actually hadn't been interrogated.
Trying to go forward here.
Let's try.
So you might say all that matters is the amount
of the DNA because it's DNA to RNA and protein.
But that's actually not true, and this picture explains why.
Metazoans, multicellular organisms, developed chromosomes so that during a cell
division, each daughter cell gets the same DNA.
So let's just say you had three copies.
When the cell is getting ready to divide,
it would make six copies, and each chromosome would be sent to daughter
cells so that it would be parceled three and three.
But these extrachromosomal DNA particles lack centromeres, and as a consequence,
the three become six, but they can be parceled six and zero or five
and one or four and two or three and three.
Notice two things just happened. One, you've doubled the potential
copy number. I always wondered, how do you get 30, 40, 50,
60, 70 copies? The second thing you've done is you've increased the
variance, which is what Darwin taught us is the fuel for
evolution.
So what this allows and what this does is instead of every cell division creating
an equal set, every cell division actually creates a
bell-shaped curve, and it keeps going.
And that creates this enormous variation and the ability to be
selected for under various conditions incredibly quickly.
And this has profound implications.
Permit a speculation for a moment.
Bacteria have circular genomes and plasmids.
Every single cell is a unique organism.
Daughter cells don't have to have the same DNA as mother cells, and the species
evolves very quickly. That's why we struggle with antibiotic resistance.
Plants and animals developed chromosomes so that each daughter cell gets the
same DNA during a cell division. It's as if cancer pulled
an ancient trick by grafting these circular DNA structures
onto the chromosomal backbone.
So at this point,
I connected with Howard Chang. I gave a talk at Stanford in
2017, and Howard, working with Will Greenleaf, had just developed this
ATAC-seq technology to look at chromatin accessibility.
And he just published a paper on how chromatin accessibility
signatures are very informative in cancer.
And Howard came to me after my talk and said, "Paul, I think I'm seeing
accessibility signatures that come from the
extrachromosomal DNA particles that you described." And that started a working
relationship that continues through today and the work that I'm going to talk
about.
It also is critically done in very close collaboration with Howard.
We also began a Cancer Grand Challenges award, for which we're incredibly
grateful because it allowed us to work in a completely different way.
Talk about global and partnership.
This has allowed us to work in a very different way.
The schematic on the right shows how by using this, we
can-Take and combine technologies to
interrogate the biology in samples,
experimental models, and in clinical samples from patients, so that we
continue to learn from patients and we develop computational tools as a
framework that we try to export and share with the broader community.
What we've learned to date is that there are at least two ways that
extrachromosomal DNA can form. We've learned that paired double-strand breaks,
particularly in the context of tumor cells that have lost a tumor suppressor like
P53, creates these circular DNA
particles. There's nothing that's going to prevent the ligation of
these ends. But
you have to have lost a suppressor, and on top of that,
you have to have a gene that encodes a gain of function.
The genome is huge, so these events could be happening, but it's only when you pick
up a Myc or an EGF receptor in the context of a suppressor loss, that
the then non-Mendelian inheritance goes off to the races.
Another mechanism that's been described by many, including Peter Lee, Don
Cleveland, Peter Campbell, David Pelman, and others, is
chromothripsis. That is when a chromosome lags and it goes into a
micronucleus. It can get chopped to bits and the particles reassemble
into extrachromosomal DNA using very much the same sorts of rules.
So one of the most important things we did was we brought in Andrea Ventura, who
does mouse genetic modeling. And Andrea Ventura used the Cre-Lox
system. In Cre-Lox, you typically put what you want to get rid
of into the garbage can. That's actually a circle.
So what Andrea wisely did was, what if you put what you wanted
into that circle? And that actually he's used to model extrachromosomal
DNA in a very programmable fashion.
And what's important about Andrea's work is that it actually
shows that ecDNA is transformative in these
very tightly controlled mouse genetic models.
So then we start thinking more about this issue of inheritance.
Everybody knows this picture, Darwin's branching tree of life,
that was describing evolution, but then became very
critical for thinking about cancer evolution.
And the idea is you take pieces of the DNA and you sequence, and you can say,
"I see the mutation here, but not here, but not here, but there." And you use
that to infer whether a mutation is clonal or
truncal, or whether it's in a branch.
But that assumes chromosomes, because Darwin
was studying finches. If Darwin had made this
picture from bacteria, it would look very different.
And realizing this and this concept of random
inheritance, essentially that the heredity by descent actually becomes
random, this has profound implications
because that means that cancer can follow
non-Mendelian inheritance when it's driven by extrachromosomal
DNA. And we've found this again and again.
You can really predict how this actually works.
So the extrachromosomal DNA has profound implications for
what cancers do by how these cancer-causing genes are
inherited.
And this has important implications for thinking about drug
resistance. You can imagine this is a process that continues.
Everything from oncogene switching to the development of, quote,
"new oncogenes" that drive that switch to resistance to targeted
therapies, all of these, it has been demonstrated that
extrachromosomal
DNA can actually drive these features.
It also can drive immunosuppression.
We brought James Chen in on our team, who's been doing brilliant
work. There's a paper by Tole et al.
that's in bioRxiv that shows that ecDNA suppresses the
cGAS-STING system. So this has profound
implications for cancer drug resistance.
EcDNA also changes what the genes
actually do. And then this was a schematic that was put forward by Shaowei
Yan, a graduate student at Howard's lab, a postdoc in Howard's lab, whom I
co-mentor,
and who's now in my lab. And she's pointed out here some very important
features of ecDNA. First of all,
the presence on these circular ecDNA particles changes how the
genes are expressed or regulated in cis.
So when we think about gene regulation, we think about loops in which enhancers
become proximal to promoters to drive gene expression.
So you think about a string with a bunch of loops and things that are far apart
from each other or too far apart to interact, and you have insulator units in
between. Imagine taking that string and turning it
into a loop. Now everything is close, and the insulators don't
matter. It goes even beyond that. There's new forms of regulation
in trans, as circles interact with each other in something called
ecDNA hubs, that was described by King Hung in
Howard's lab. And these hubs allow you to have interactions between enhancers and
promoters across circles, sometimes even bearing different
oncogenes, sharing transcriptional machinery to dramatically
increase the output. When you take those features and you add them
onto this powerful non-Mendelian inheritance, you have a
recipe for genomic chaos.
So this is what these hubs actually look like.
You can see them visually, and you can actually do
experiments that show that these are actually functional units that are
dramatically increasing transcription.
So I've actually just set up for you a paradox.
Said that ecDNA is randomly inherited and also said that
ecDNA particles can interact with each other in trans in a favorable
fashion. So you would predict that they'd want to keep those particles
together. But how would that actually work?
Well, we looked at it in a paper that was spearheaded by King Hung, Matt Jones from
Howard's lab, and Ivy Wang and EJ Curtis, EJ's right here in the third
row,
from my lab,
to actually ask the questionIs this happening and how does it
work? And the answer is they are co-inherited.
And the real question is how? And I think the breakthrough came from Ivy Wang, a
post-doc in my lab. Normally, genes are supposed to stop
transcribing during mitosis. But when they're on extra
chromosomal DNA, as you can see here, this is nascent RNA fish
looking at the MYC transcript.
The ecDNA is when it's on the circles, it can reintegrate back into
chromosomes. That's the HSR. And you can see same gene on a
circle transcribes during mitosis, but stops transcribing when it
goes back onto chromosomes. And that becomes critical because in fact, working
with Ben Cravatt, we were able to show that if you blocked transcription
initiation, you blocked the co-inheritance of these particles.
Another area of genomic chaos is some recent work that was spearheaded by
Hyerim Yee
and Shuzhang, co-mentored by Howard Chang and myself.
I always wondered, where do amplified fusion oncogenes come from?
And there's so much structural variation that you might think about arising from
ecDNA. Could that be a potent source?
So by integrating
sequencing and this tool called Amplicon Architect that Vineet Bafna developed and
will tell you about, we looked at the genome structure and the transcriptional
output in human cancers of many, many different types.
And it turns out that ecDNA is a factory for structural
variation and for creating genomic
fusions that actually result in transcript
fusions. And that in fact, they
are all over many different parts of the body.
We focused on the PVT1-MYC fusion
and identified the gain-of-function mechanisms by
which this fusion has enhanced activity relative to the wild type
transcript, but we also see it in different cancer types as depicted
here. That's a completely open landscape, and Hyerim Yee is giving a talk
about this here at the meeting, which I would encourage you to go
to. So then this raises yet another interesting
question. If they don't have centromeres, how do they get to daughter cells
during a cell division? Well, there's a trick here.
Episomal viral particles like human papillomavirus.
Look at the pictures on the top. Those green are the ecDNA.
Notice how they're taking a hitchhike onto chromosomes.
Do ecDNAs look like this? Work back from Jeff Wahl's
lab back in 2000 shows a pattern that looks remarkably
similar. But how on earth does this actually work?
So for episomal viruses, you have viral DNA
elements that interact with viral proteins that interact with specific
regions of the chromosome, and in work that was spearheaded by
Venkat Sankar and King Hung,
both graduate students in Howard's lab, Venkat is now in mine,
and we basically went to look at this.
And they developed a really clever idea.
Chop up genomic DNA, put it into plasmids, and see what sticks
around as retention elements.
And you can see here, you get profiles like this that show when you encode certain
sequences, the plasmids stick around.
So what's on them? Well, it turns out they're loaded with promoters,
and they're CpG-rich elements.
And it gets even more interesting. They're additive.
So you can imagine it like in this schematic on the right, two is better than one,
three is better than two, four is better than three.
And there's lots of these elements.
So you can begin to imagine a physical basis for how this might
actually work. So then we went to human cancers
from public databases like the TCGA.
And lo and behold, you have these retention elements very close to
oncogenes. In fact, whenever you have an oncogene containing ecDNA, you
have these retention elements. What they're doing is they're keeping them sticking
around. And in fact, they have to be hypomethylated.
You can see here that their signatures are those of hypomethylation, and
when you experimentally methylate those regions,
they no longer work as retention elements.
So that raises yet another really interesting question.
That suggests that there might be a protein machinery that's sitting in between.
So we decided to look at that, or at least pieces of that.
And I just want to state one
fact that people haven't thought that much about, which is mitotic bookmarking.
There's regions on chromosomes that have to stay open so that they're ready to
go right after mitosis. These are called bookmarked regions, and
it's pioneering transcription factors and chromatin remodelers that do that
job. And Katarina Kraft did a
mitotic Hi-C on this. And lo and behold, what we see is that
promoter regions on the ecDNA are physically talking
to
bookmarked enhancer regions that are loaded with transcription factor
binding sites on the chromosome. So now you're beginning to get a sense
of how this might actually work. This is machinery that normally is
used to regulate gene transcription and regulation,
but the ecDNAs have pirated it to use that.
And that actually suggests that looking at the
proteins that are involved in that process might be a very fertile
area for thinking about ecDNA-directed therapies.
Just to point out one other thing about this, which is that
it doesn't conflict with random segregation, because what you end
up having here, imagine Disneyland when the buses go and there's a free-for-all
running for the seats. It's exactly the same sort of a process.
And just to finish, I'm going to go to a few important clinical
points. Jens Lubec, sitting in the audience, and Vineet Bafna and I and other
colleagues tried to ask what this means, particularly thinking about this issue
about truncal versus branch and when does it happen?
So we went to two pre-cancers. We went to people with Barrett's esophagus who are
at risk of getting cancer. And in two studies, one that was led by
Rebecca Fitzgerald at Cambridge, a study that was a snapshot
study, and one that was led by Patty Gallipo and Tom
Paulson at the Fred Hutch, where they looked at...
tumor samples or tissue samples over space and time
from those with Barrett's who did or did not get cancer.
What we were really able to see was that in fact,
ecDNA arose during high-grade dysplasia, always in the
context of p53. And if it arose, those people would go on to
get esophageal adenocarcinoma. That has really big implications because it
means we need to look across other cancers or other
pre-cancers to see ecDNA, because if it's there, it's
likely to be a huge problem for these patients.
So working with Maryam Jamal Hanjani, Charlie Swanton, and
others in a study that was spearheaded by Chris Bailey and Oriol Pich, we looked at
the Genomic England's data set to ask how common is
ecDNA and in what cancer types, and what does it mean?
So looking at close to 15,000 cancer samples of
39 different types, we've seen that in at least
17.1% of all cancers, the ecDNA or
that the amplifications arose as ecDNA.
We don't know if they're still there, but we know for certain that they arose as
these circular ecDNA particles. And
this is biased because these are largely earlier phase tumors.
But you can see here huge spectrums bearing different
cargos suggesting that tissue context is dramatically
shaping the landscape of ecDNA. And in fact, they
contain oncogenes, they contain immunomodulatory genes,
they contain regulatory elements in all various combinations.
And in fact, when they have the immunomodulatory genes, they have reduced T
cell fractions. Most importantly, the patients who have
ecDNA in their tumors do worse than all other cancer patients.
These people are different, and that's why we need to be paying so much
attention to them and what we can do about it.
We are continuing to push the envelope of this biology.
I'm just pointing out a study that we've done with our colleague, Anton
Henson. He's going to be chairing a major session tomorrow on
ecDNA biology, trying to understand what actually happens when the
elements, the ecDNAs can't tether to the chromosomes,
and what are the consequences of that.
And also, I think I've mentioned this issue of the innate immune system
and ecDNA.
So
this conversation started with ecDNA 12 years
ago when only about three people in the world were actually interested in the
topic. And it's culminated yesterday in the
publication of an article in
the anniversary issue of "The Hallmarks of Cancer," pointing
out that ecDNA really is a critical
enabler of the hallmark of cancer in those patients in whom that actually
happens. This field has to move forward quickly.
The patients need it. The door is open.
We look forward to collaborating with you, and I am grateful to my
colleagues. In particular, the Cancer Grand Challenges program has allowed
us to work in a completely different way.
I hope the data that I've shown you speaks to the power of that model, the
people in my lab, the people in many other labs, and our ability to work
together. And at that point, I'll say thank you.
So I think we have time for a couple of questions, and then we can
move on to the next talk.
I just wonder what is the soft belly
of extra chromosomal
DNA? So this is relevant for two issues.
First, why normal cells
don't have, except maybe lymphocytes during development, don't have extra
chromosomal DNA? And then what
is the potential sensitivity of
cancer cells
that carry extra chromosomal DNA that we can target?
You've asked two really fundamental questions.
The first, and we've actually been having an ongoing conversation, Maryam
Jamal Hanjani, Charlie Swanton, and I, around this first point about normal.
Let's just imagine a situation, right, where you get paired double-strand
breaks or you get a lagging chromosome in chromothripsis, and you
circularize a particle. First of all, if your tumor suppressors
are intact, it's unlikely that that cell is going to go forward.
What's the likelihood of having being down two copies of p53 in one cell in
your body? Not small, okay? But then this has to happen, but the
genome is huge. So unless you put in
a true gain-of-function gene,
there will be no selection for it. So it's a stochastic issue.
Rare event plus rare event, or relatively rare event plus relatively rare event.
You'd never see it, you'd never know about it unless you picked up a MYC or
an EGF receptor, and then the non-Mendelian inheritance and the rapid
selection would drive it. So I think that may be behind why we don't
"see it" in normal cells. The second question is, what are the
sensitivities that are created? There's a lot of work that's going on right now,
both in biotech companies and also in academic labs, as we're
trying to understand what this type of
DNA does. I think my colleague Ben
Cravatt has a very good analogy of this.
For years, people thought about microsatellite instability.
And it was just a state that was biological interest, but nothing you could
do about it until the Werner helicase story came along.
We anticipate that ecDNA is going to be very similar, that
there are likely to be differences in how specific enzymes are used or
required that create synthetic lethal opportunities.
Thank you for your nice talk.
Now we know ecDNA can contribute to
therapeutic resistance. But however, do you think
some oncogenes
amplified in ecDNA. Can we target these
amplified oncogenes
for cancer therapy?
Can I make sure that I understood that question?
Could you actually repeat it? Let me make sure I understand it.
Okay.
Can we target the amplified oncogenes
by ecDNA for therapy strategy?
I'm sorry, I'm not catching it.
Can we try it one more time? I apologize.
Okay.
Do you think we can target amplified
oncogenes by ecDNA for cancer therapy?
Oh, I see. I think what you're asking is could you use
targeted therapy against oncogenes that are encoded on ecDNAs?
Is that what you're asking?
Yeah.
Okay. The answer is it doesn't work.
And the reason that it doesn't work, and we've shown this experimentally, is
because the cancer cells rapidly change the copy number.
And frequently what they'll do is they become dependent on another
amplified oncogene that is present on another ecDNA particle
that was there at very low frequency before.
I'll give other examples. Take prostate cancer. This is slightly different.
If you look in prostate cancer, you see very little ecDNA before treatment,
but after they become resistant to androgen deprivation, they start
developing ecDNAs, including the androgen receptor gene MYC and
others. I think we're going to see that again and again.
Thank you.
Great. So at this point, I'm going to turn this over to my colleague,
Professor Vineet Bafna, and at the end, the three of us will be on stage to answer
more questions.
I'd like to thank the organizers for this invitation.
I'm really delighted to speak.
We are a computational lab.
I'm going to have my presentation start.
And
over the years, we have developed many tools for
analyzing ecDNA.
And because Paul did such a wonderful job of introducing
ecDNA and describing some of the properties, I'm going to sort of jump
right in. So,
one of our sort of the foundational tools that we have built is
this AmpliconSuite pipeline, and actually Jens, who's in the
audience, has done the lion's share of the work to both
develop and maintain it over the years.
And very simply, it takes
whole genome sequencing data, paired-end sequencing from
Illumina as input, and it looks at the
copy number regions, specifically at focally amplified copy number
regions, small regions of the genome that have high copy numbers, and
investigates the structure underlying them.
And
what it does is it actually builds a graph out of
these amplified regions, looking both at high copy numbers and
the paired-end reads that connect distant high copy number
regions. And the graph then provides a framework for
future analysis.
Specifically,
we can analyze a graph, look for cycles, and cycles
of a particular kind are generally representative of
ecDNA. So it's relatively simple and crude, but it does work,
and we also make other calls, those of breakage-fusion-bridge
cycles, complex non-cyclic, and linear amplicons.
And today, I'll go through the thinking process that we
have about making these classifications, how they work, where they might
not work, and so on.
All right? But before we say that, the toolkit is
available for those in the audience who might be considering using it for their own
research.
It's a very stable tool now. Many people have used it.
We've used it on almost 60,000 or more than 60,000
whole genome samples. And it
provides at least a
first-level
classification of individuals whose cancers might carry
ecDNA. And Paul alluded to this, there are many studies like
this.
The study led by Charlie Swanton and Paul Michelle, and
in this, they looked at nearly 15,000 individuals
and find that individuals with ecDNA do
universally worse, even when you compare them to individuals that
have amplifications that are
chromosomal or at least not extrachromosomal.
But we know that all amplifications are
not extrachromosomal. So this
slide illustrates that on the left side and on the right side, you see the
epidermal growth factor receptor gene amplified to nearly 100
copies. So focally amplified regions.
But on the left, when you look at the PHASH data, it clearly is
extrachromosomal. You can see the signal outside of the chromosomes.
And on the right side, you can clearly see that it's intrachromosomal.
Right? And then the question that arises is when we look at these copy numbers
and the amplicon graphs, how can we
say confidently that these are ecDNA? Right?
And I want to
bring some nuance into this discussion because it's an important one.
And the point is that when you look at chromosomal amplifications,
which often show up in cytogenetics as homogeneously staining regions
or HSRs, they're not all the same, right?
There could be many ways in which these HSRs could be built.
One of them is that there could be a native intrachromosomal
mechanism that's creating the amplification, and another
case might be that there's ecDNA that re-integrated
into the chromosomeMost likely in some non-native location,
and that's what's shown on the rightmost panel.
So you can see these different states, and there could be others
of HSRs and ecDNA. And then the question
is, how can we distinguish between these and
what are the genomic signatures?
So I want to go to the right point first because that's, I think,
interesting. If it was indeed ecDNA that reintegrated into the
chromosome, you would see the same genomic signal.
It would be very hard too, and indeed, we don't do a good job of
discriminating between them. But then the question is,
are they truly stable HSRs? And I'm going to show you we have many such examples,
but here's one where you can see in the cell line that
you have the gene, MDM2 in this case,
amplified as both extrachromosomal and
intrachromosomal in the same sample.
So perhaps it's not necessarily meaningful to
classify it as ecDNA or HSR, but rather we should think of
these as ecDNA competent. And if we want to do a more careful
analysis, we may have to go down to single cell level.
And indeed, there are many nice
recent papers. Jake Lee's work working with Saurabh
Shah, also Matt Jones and in my lab, Geno Prasad, looking
at cytogenetic data, are trying to
delineate at a single cell level whether or not we have
HSR formation or ecDNA. So that's one part of the story.
The other part, of course, is that you could also have intrachromosomal
DNA that are
natively formed. And so if you
try to distinguish between the extrachromosomal ones and the
intrachromosomal that are native, we do very good job of
discriminating just simply with genomic signatures, because indeed the
genomic signatures are quite different.
You can see this
in this unpublished data where Ivy Wong from
Paul Michelle's lab and working with Jens, they indeed looked at
a huge number of metaphase cells, almost 175
experiments. It's a lot of work where they tried to figure
this data out.
So now the question is, how are these intrachromosomal amplifications
formed? And one of the ones that we see is they often
start with this telomere crisis, which is a
destabilizing effect. And then there must be some way
to stabilize it. There are many fates that can happen.
Jake Lee's and others' work showed that the two distinct
chromosomes could join together and form
these translocation bridge amplifications.
Or this might lead to a lagging chromosome, which through chromotrips
this might end up creating ecDNA. But we are interested in
another mechanism where these cycles continue for a while, and then they
reacquire the telomere and form stable intrachromosomal
amplifications. And we have been working on these
both with optical genome maps and with some Oxford
Nanopore data. And you can see on the left side that you can see
this fold back
structure of amplification, where the same region through
repeated foldbacks can create strong focal amplification signatures,
which is then stabilized and ends up as a stable intrachromosomal
amplification. So this question about how they can
stabilize is also somewhat not well understood.
In fact, a very old letter from Mack Untuck to
Elizabeth Blackburn, both great scientists in the telomere
field, suggested that there might be this healing process that
allows these broken ends to reacquire telomeres.
And it's not well understood, but now we have some data where we can
start picking at this problem. And you can see in this one
example where there's a very nice breakage fusion bridge amplification
on chromosome 20, but then it's followed by a translocation.
It's actually hijacking a portion of chromosome 15.
You can see the increase in copy number and probably reacquires the telomere
through this translocation. So hopefully with new data, we are
able to get at the bottom line of these questions.
So now when we have these two amplifications, a stable
intrachromosomal amplification and extrachromosomal amplification,
we can ask if these are indeed different functionally.
And we have a lot of data. But I'll point to this example that Paul
alluded to where when you look at extrachromosomal DNA and target
them
with this,
in this case it's EGFR, it's targeted with
erlotinib, which is an EGFR inhibitor.
It very quickly adapts. It changes copy number, it goes down
to an HSR state with very low copy number.
When you remove the drug,
the copy numbers rise again, thereby showing that ecDNA can quickly adapt
and develop resistance. Now, when we look at the same data in
same gene amplified as a stable breakage fusion bridge
amplification, the copy number actually remains stable.
Resistance is much harder to create, and even
in the resistant cell lines, we still see this amplification suggesting that
perhaps when we look at targeted therapy,
we should really differentiate between the stable intrachromosomal
amplifications and
the extrachromosomal amplification.
So
what's left? So one thing is that even though we can
detect extrachromosomal DNA,
it's not very clear what's on the extrachromosomal DNA.
The problem is actually surprisingly hard.
And this picture hopefully can illustrate some of that.
So here on the left is an amplicon graph that amplicon architect
or any sort of genomic analysis tool can create.
If you want to know what's on the ecDNA, we sort of know that it's these
segments A, B, C, and D.But we don't quite know in which order, in
which orientation, and moreover, there might be high multiplicities of
these segments in the genome. And so if you start extracting
cycles from this graph, you can get many possible structures,
and some combination of them form the true
ecDNA repertoire. So it's definitely a problem that one would like
to investigate further. With long reads and
with some principle of using some kind of an Occam's razor
saying maybe there are a few cycles that dominate, we might be
able to disambiguate some of these structures.
So in this particular case, we have so many species, but if you
have some long reads that,
for example, a long read that supports going from the
segment B to the segment A to C, it can quickly
disambiguate and say perhaps the structure on the right is the
correct structure. And the way we think about these problems is
to then say, can we explain the entire copy number of
this amplicon using only a small number of
cycles, which together explain all the structural variants,
but also these different sub constraints that these long reads provide us?
And it's sort of a challenging optimization
problem. And when we solve it, we end up with very interesting structures.
We have validated, of course, through simulations, but now we are looking at
some complex structures and trying to see if the actual
sequence that we predict makes sense.
And so I'll give you a couple of examples.
These are all well-regarded cell lines that people in the
community use. Polo3.20 exists
as an ecDNA, and when we analyze this, it turns
out to have a very complex structure, almost over
4.5 million base pairs long. When we look at it with our long
read tools, we find that there are two cycles, and in fact, our
recent data suggests that there might even be a one mega cycle of
8 million base pairs. And so now the question is,
do we believe these cycles? We are sort of picking at it
point by point, but there are certain structural features that increase
our confidence. One of them is that in this cycle, you can see
that the PBT1 actually has a rearrangement that puts it
upstream of the oncogene MYC, and that's a key
rearrangement that's actually required for the
MYC to be actually active and have high
transcription. And so this increases our confidence that we have the
right structures.
We also looked at another cell line that has been studied quite a lot in the
community, PC3DM. Surprisingly, there are not many published
reports of its true structure. And when we look at it, the
structure looks also very complicated, almost 4.5 million
base pairs. And
you can see many genes are repeated multiple times,
something that it would be hard to sort of pick at and figure
out whether it's a true structure or not.
And we cannot say, of course, that it's entirely correct.
But again,
working with King Hung who graduated from Howard Chang's
lab, we did this CRISPR-Cas experiment.
So we take some guide RNA, and we cut at different locations where the
guide matches, and that should give certain fragments.
In this case, if our structure was correct, it would give you three
fragments, two of which would be in excess of 1.5 million base
pairs. And you can see in this gel that only with this
guide RNA and with no other, you see exactly these fragments.
So that increases our confidence.
Then we also looked at some of the genes that co-occur on this and
did a multi-FISH experiment with Ivy Wong.
And you can see very nicely that these three
oncogenes MYC, SAMD1/2, and FER1L6 all
actually co-occur as
ecDNA, again, increasing our confidence that this is a true structure.
So the claim being that with long reads and with newer
data, we are better able to analyze and
reconstruct the true sequence of ecDNA. All right.
So finally, in the small time that I have, we are
also looking at chromatin capture data to see if we can
understand the three-dimensional structure of ecDNA.
And I won't have time to go into the algorithms.
You can definitely look at the paper.
It turns out that ecDNA have a very interesting and complex
three-dimensional structure, not mediated solely by
polymer physics, but actually by the transcription factors and the other
proteins that might bind and change them.
And
we learned many things about them.
For example, it wasn't known if the ecDNA would have a disk-like
configuration or occupy the entire three-dimensional volume, and our results
suggest that they do occupy this three-dimensional volume.
We also did some orthogonal validation using high-resolution
microscopy in a collaboration with
Guy Nir's lab, and we can see very high correlation, even though
both of these methodologies are not to a resolution where you can
get down to get the exact structure, but the high correlation from these
independent methods also increase our confidence.
So how can we
study and see if these structures actually
can help us? Well, one thing is that they do a better job of
predicting CTCF binding sites. In the matrix on the
left, the upper half of the matrix shows the raw Hi-C data,
whereas the bottom half shows the much clearer data that you get
with the three-dimensional structure.
And on the right, you can see that actually the
ecDNA can be split into two topological domains.
One of them, as was shown by Anton Hansen and colleagues, that
has genes that are very highly expressed, and the other
side, the genes are completely silent, so also supported by the
3D structure.All right. So I think I want to stop
here and not take too much time. What we are trying to do, we are
very focused on the community, and we would encourage everybody to use
our tools. Jens also has developed this amplicon
repository. It's a place where we try and deposit all
the structures that we get, and we'll populate it with more
information in the future. And I also encourage people who use our
tools to both deposit this data site, but also they can use
it for their own research. I think Jens has a very nice poster
describing some of the
ways in which you can mine this repository, for example, to find
co-occurring
genes in ecDNA.
All right. So summary, I think ecDNA, for this session, we don't
need to reargue this. But
just as a second point, we are continuing to develop computational methods.
We'd love to work with all of you to analyze your data and
also to provide our tools for your analysis.
And I also want to acknowledge many, many people.
In the interest of time, I don't have time to sort of name
all of them, but certainly
Jens and
Biswa, and many others in my lab, and many other colleagues
in the team E-Dynamic have been of great
help to us over the years. Thank
you.
Yeah. We have time for a couple of questions.
Go ahead, Jake.
Okay. Thanks so much for a great talk.
Just a very simple question. Do you have any advice about those missing
SVs when we reconstruct the ecDNA?
Sometimes I think not only challenging for just identifying the ecDNA itself, but
also if we think about those multiple cycles of ecDNAs,
multi-copy ecDNA in one molecule, I think those missing
SVs can play quite a bit of role. So how do you resolve
that?
Right. It's a very good question from Jake Lee, who's
definitely an expert in the field.
So the question is that if you have two ecDNA
species that share a genomic region, how can you
disambiguate them, right? Is that a fair question?
Well, one way that you want to think about it is that if you have two
ecDNA, they are likely not to have the same copy
number. If they have the same copy number, there's really no difference.
You can treat them as two molecules or one combined molecule, and you'd be fine.
Now, if you have one ecDNA, and I
actually had a slide, but I didn't have time to show it today.
If you have one ecDNA, which has, say, 90 copies, and the other ecDNA which
shares a segment with 10 copies, if you treat them like one
ecDNA, you would have to take those 90 copies and explain
them nine times, suggesting that the same breakpoint is
reused nine times in the cycle, followed by one cycle.
We believe that breakpoint reuse for a segment to break and rejoin
at exactly the same base pair location is more unlikely.
So in that case, we would split them.
When they have very similar copy numbers, we treat them as one, just
to give the Occam's razor like principle.
They could still be two species. But that's a great question. Thanks.
Question.
That was lovely work. Tim Lai, WashU.
As you know, long-read DNA sequencing, especially on the
ONT platform, is fantastic for resolving breakpoints in the
genome and structural variants. Has it had any role in
improving your ability to detect breakpoints in these extrachromosomal elements?
I'm afraid because there's an echo on that side, I'm not able to hear very well.
But are you saying that is it true that the Oxford Nanopore
allows you to better retrieve the breakpoints?
Yeah.
Was that your question?
Correct.
Yes. Absolutely. I'm sorry if I didn't say that clearly.
For all our long-read reconstructions, we are using Oxford Nanopore,
and it gives us two advantages. I think the biggest one is that it allows us
to get at breakpoints, especially in the repetitive
regions where short reads are not able to fully map
unambiguously. So that's one part, but sometimes it can also
connect two breakpoints and say that not only those two breakpoints occur, that
they occur in sequence, and that using those as constraints,
we are better able to disambiguate the structure.
Thanks.
Thank you.
One last question, maybe. Yes.
So I was just wondering, you mentioned about ecDNA.
It looks like it's ectochromatin.
So do you predict this time DNA with the
ectochromatin share the similar governing principle
for replication, epigenetic profile,
and transcription? Do you find any
special replication origin
site for this
ecDNA? I think it might be
with structure like ectochromatin.
I'm afraid I had trouble hearing you.
I'm sorry. I just want to-- The ecDNA is like
ectochromatin, that it's similar like heat combining,
very like the chromosome organization.
So it share the similar principle like replication,
epigenetic, and transcription these time things.
Right.
Not like pure DNA. These are actually for this, right?
So is your question about the chromatin organization of ecDNA and whether it's
different from the chromosome or?
Yeah. Is that DNA or chromatin?
Yes. EcDNA are highly accessible.
This has been shown in multiple studies, including ones by
Howard Chang and Paul Michell. The ecDNA
chromatin, it's very loosely bound to the histones, and so
the genes on ecDNA are like genes on steroids.
They're hyperactive. And this has been shown.
In fact-It's to the point where you can look at single-cell
ATAC-seq data and almost predict where the ecDNA
are just by looking at the high level of ATAC-seq
signal throughout the ecDNA region.
And Matt Jones, for example, has a tool for detecting
ecDNA just using single-cell ATAC-seq.
So yes, it's very loosely bound. I'm sorry, you had many parts
to your question. Because I had trouble hearing, maybe we could take that
offline and I could try and answer it, because I had trouble hearing
from on the stage.
Yeah, I'm sorry. It's my
accent, I know. So
I question like
this, you mentioned about
oncogene mutation actually everywhere,
even in some normal tissue. Just wondering, they're like
ec chromatin, they are normal physiology or development
in the
function?
So it's not exclusively in cancer cell, I'm
right?
Right.
Sorry, Paul, what did you say? Maybe you could come because I just have trouble.
I
think I understand your question.
And you can tell me if I have this right.
I think you're saying that we've learned that mutations happen in normal
tissue and they're not cancer. So and then the question is very similar to
the question that was asked during my talk.
Do ecDNAs occur in normal tissue? That's what you're asking, right?
Yeah. I just wonder is the kind of normal function in physiology, right?
Okay. So
this is what we know.
If you look by sequencing, you see
mutations in non-cancerous tissue.
To date, we have never seen ecDNA in normal tissue,
only in highly dysplastic tissue.
So that begs the question, does this process of double-strand breaks creating
a circle,
does that happen in normal tissue?
My guess, this is a hypothesis because we have no data on that, is that it
probably does. But if it happens in the cell with intact tumor
suppressors,
that won't go forward. More importantly, the genome is huge.
So what you're most likely to get is something that has no gain of function.
So the real thing is, if you have a cell that's lost its suppressors
and you pick up a MYC or an EGF receptor inside that circle,
then you have ecDNA and the non-Mendelian inheritance will drive cancer.
Right.
Of course. I think in the interest of time, I'm going to introduce
my colleague, Professor Myall-Ghanayem.
Okay. Thank you everyone. So I'm going to introduce a housekeeping point,
perhaps, and apologies in advance.
Any questions for me, take them on the other side so that clearly there's a problem
with perhaps echo.
Right. I just need my talk to come up. There we go.
So thank you Paul, Vanee. You've really laid the grounds for
my talk, and it's a great pleasure and honor to be here today.
For an 8:00 a.m. educational session, Paul, you're right.
I think it's a really good turnout, so thank you all for being here.
And thank you to Paul and Alice and the organizers at AACR.
So I'm going to get started, and all my data are unpublished, so I'd be grateful if
we could avoid posting these online.
Now, I will come back to TmyDNAmic also at the end, but I start with
acknowledging
really two large consortia that now are
global,
embedded within the TRACERx lung cancer evolution program and a
national autopsy program, both of which are flagship studies and have been
funded by Cancer Research UK over the last decade or so.
And many of them you see here. Very much so under
the mentorship of Charlie for the last decade and a half, we've been rolling out
these studies. The analysis continues.
I'm presenting data today predominantly from Karen Grimes and Jeanette Kittel.
Karen is in Nikki McGranahan's lab, and Jeanette is a PhD student in my lab.
So TRACERx is a UK-wide national study in
which patients with operable early-stage non-small cell lung
cancer undergo curative intent surgery.
And when we opened the study in 2014, our USP at the time
was that we would be the first that would try to
spatially and temporally try and understand the evolution of non-small
cell lung cancer from diagnosis through to relapse and beyond,
or cure and remission, depending on treatment response.
But really the USP was this multi-regional deep genomic
sequencing and transcriptional profiling to try and understand, at the very
least, at diagnosis, spatial genomic heterogeneity.
And these patients are followed up for at least five years, during
which at least half the cohort have sadly experienced a recurrence or
relapse, may undergo treatment for metastatic disease.
And beyond that, a subset of patients will be co-recruited into the National PEACE
Autopsy Program, which on the right-hand side, you get a glance of the real
depth and wealth of metastatic sample that we can achieve
through research autopsy sampling.
And the idea was that when you dovetail these studies together, you can truly
understand the disease from diagnosis through to death, so that we can
understand tumor evolution in the context of the cancer cell, but also the
microenvironment in which it exists.
So today, I'm showing you data from a whole genome cohort
across the TRACERx and the PEACE Autopsy program.
Over 100 patients in whom we've spatially analyzed over
360 samples of the primary tumor, multi-regional.
Subset of patients in whom their disease has relapsed.
They've undergone either, whilst alive, metastatic sampling or then
subsequently had an autopsy, and then we've had a very detailed
anatomical sampling of the body and the metastatic
sitesAnd great efforts in the
field, I mention here the Peacock Consortium, have
demonstrated the real utility, at the very
least, research, and arguably discovery value of deep
whole genome sequencing in the cancer field.
And of course, there is a cost implication.
But given that not so long ago, Peacock published and demonstrated that
over 50% of potential cancer driver events are these
large-scale structural variants, there is a real unmet
need to better understand the structural variant landscape in
cancer so that not only might we discover novel
drivers yet to be known, but also the potential drug target discovery.
And the deep whole genome picture, of course, we expect gives
us more of a complete understanding, at least here.
I'm presenting today lung cancer somatic genomes.
We can look at somatic mutations to a greater extent, importantly, including the
non-coding regions of the genome, copy number profiles that
allow us to take into account with greater resolution, purity,
karyotyping, ploidy.
But also these structural variants that I'm focusing on in the first part of my
talk, trying to give a sense of at least the landscape of these chromosomal
alterations in primary lung cancer, and importantly, the complexity
in terms of intra, but also
intra-chromosomal alterations.
And by virtue of sequencing the whole genome, one can look at
other elements. Paul touched on this, but we're beginning to
also investigate mitochondrial mutations and the role that some of these other
genomic components play in tumor evolution.
When you look in the primary non-small cell lung cancers, treatment-naive setting,
multi-regional sampling, you see a real variation in terms of the
landscape or the complexity of the structural variant genome.
Some can be very simple. You see here a patient, three
primary lung cancer regions, sequence.
We see five structural variants, but they all are focused on one part of the
genome. And in some patients, the primary tumor is really quite
vastly highly rearranged.
Here we see a multitude of structural variants, both intra and
interchromosomal, and we can see that they impact different parts of the
genome.
Here's the cohort of almost 130 patients, multi-regional
sampling, but at this point, we're just asking the question, well, when you look at
the unique number of structural variants, how does it vary from one
patient to the next? Well, we see great heterogeneity in the stage of
primary disease diagnosis, at least when you're looking at the number of structural
variants.
And unsurprisingly, we see this from the mutational data, and certainly in the
copy number data in non-small cell lung cancer.
This does seem to vary according to the histological subtype,
predominantly lung adenocarcinoma, LUAD here, or lung
squamous cell carcinoma.
And we've looked at the variety of clinical variables.
I should have said one of the advantages of the longitudinal TRACERx program is
that we deeply clinically phenotype our patients from not only treatment
histories, past medical histories, but also the anti-cancer
therapies that we intervene during follow-up, but also clinical variables,
whether it's smoking history, whether it's environmental exposure, and so on.
And actually, the main clinical variable that trumps a correlation or
an association with structural variant burden in terms
of the number you identify, it's smoking status.
So if you're a smoker or an ex-smoker, you quit more than a year
ago, then you're more likely to have what turns out to be these
truncal structural variants, so they appear to be clonal, present in
every part of the tumor.
And again, not surprising. We see this also when we look at copy number
variations profiles or somatic mutations.
Now, because of the multi-regional sampling, we can begin to ask the question of
what kind of structural variants might we see spatially distinct
across the primary tumor mass? Well, if you just look at the number of structural
variants per patient, you see there's heterogeneity again.
Different types of structural variants can occur in the same primary
tumor, and the burden of which varies from one patient to the
next.
We also see through the multi-regional sampling, as I said, what's clonal truncal,
or what Paul referred to as branch or subclonal.
Of course, we don't have that clonal resolution because this is really just looking
at the presence or absence according to the different spatially sampled
regions. You see this variation in the number and the proportion of
structural variants across the cohort.
But what's interesting is that less than 50% of the cohort have
truncal structural variants. So we see evidence of, one could infer,
structural variants playing a role in tumor evolution on the branches,
diversifying these tumors genomically.
A couple of years ago, well, almost a decade ago, and then a few years ago, we
showed in the TRACERx program that when you look at the multiple regions of the
primary tumors, this is deep whole exome, not whole genome,
and you look at just the copy number alterations, you can identify
those tumors that harbor a very greater burden compared to other
tumors of subclonal or heterogeneous copy number
alterations, what we termed somatic copy number alteration
intra-tumor heterogeneity. Now, historically, mutational genomic
heterogeneity has been associated with poor prognosis.
That's been shown by us and others in retrospective small studies in terms of
clinical outcome, disease-free survival, and overall survival.
But we demonstrated that actually copy number heterogeneity, the complexity of
these structural variants in terms of their burden and the number of them that are
subclonal in the branches, predicts for poor clinical outcome.
Not only that, after surgery, you're more likely to relapse within one year
of curative intense surgery. I'm not showing you the data here today, but this is
also anatomically relevant. You're more likely to relapse outside of the
lungs, extra-thoracically, and these patients have a higher burden of
comorbidities as well as mortality.
Okay, so that's copy number alterations and only the whole exome.
And I won't have the answer for you here today, but what we're beginning to
ask is, looking at the whole genome, what can we identify from the
structural variants and the complexity of these copy number alterations that
might decipher a little bit more,
sort of the nuances of what it is about chromosomal instability or this copy number
heterogeneity that predicts a poor outcome?So here again, we can
now infer truncal versus subclonal or branch burden
of somatic structural variants. And we see
that this can vary according to histological subtype, but whether
you've got adenocarcinoma or squamous cell carcinoma, there is
variation in terms of truncal versus subclonal.
Clearly, some structural variants appear to play a role early as opposed to late
evolution. We can look at this a little bit further with these density plots,
which I'll try to explain. They essentially give you a sense of the
crowdedness or the presence or prevalence of
within certain parts of the genome, a specific structural variant, and we can look
at the nature of these, whether it's a deletion, a duplication, inversion, and so
on. You get a sense here that these larger
structural variants are significantly enriched in the trunk of the primary
tumors, which suggests they may be selected for or present very early on in
tumorigenesis, perhaps play a role in early evolution, as
opposed to these mid-size, slightly larger, in particular the
deletions, are significantly depleted in the trunk of the primary tumors.
Hypothesizing that perhaps they play a role in the subclonal branching
or the heterogeneous evolution of these tumors.
So structural variants appear to potentially have distinguished
roles in early versus late, depending on the structural
nature, the size, and the type of structural variant.
I've not mentioned any of the temporal aspect that we've been able to begin to
capture in the TRACERx program. So here's primary tumors from over
30 patients in whom,
when alive, we were able to sample their metastatic disease through the TRACERx
program at the point of relapse and subsequent points of progression.
And at a glance, you can see a sense of now temporal heterogeneity.
So from early to late stage, primary to metastatic disease, you
can see that there's a distinct variation from one patient to the
next in terms of how many of these structural variants are on the trunk, how
many are on the branch. Again, suggesting that perhaps,
uniquely, each patient, each primary tumor, will have
different burden, different nature of structural variants, and undoubtedly, we
think this is impacted by the therapeutic intervention they
have. And again, you go back to these density plots, and we ask the question, will
the size matter again? Does the nature or type of structural variant matter?
And it does appear that those larger structural variants, perhaps,
and this is just a hypothesis, larger structural variants having the ability for
multiple hits, potentially, are enriched for being shared
between the primary and the metastases. I'll come back to this.
I propose that these perhaps have a persistent role in both early and
late tumor evolution. Could that give us some insight as to what is worth
targeting earlier on in the disease course?
So what's driving this structural variant heterogeneity?
In the second part of the talk, I'd like to talk a little bit more about the
autopsy program, because here we're trying to understand what happens in
later metastatic disease, because here we're able to infer a little bit more
about tumor evolution and the development of drug resistance.
And both Paul and Vinit touched on some of the
way in which we can profile the complexity of structural variants so they can be
quite simple. I've mentioned some of them, deletions, duplications, and so on.
Some of them can be very complex, and here are some of the mechanisms in the field
that we know may be key contributors to this structural
variant heterogeneity we see. And undoubtedly, as Paul said,
a real foundational platform for drug
resistance as a result of evolution.
But I'm focusing today on extrachromosomal DNA, not just because it's our
educational session, but because we repeatedly keep seeing evidence
of these ecDNA when we start to look
more heavily at the metastatic setting and we look at the tumors in the advanced
setting.
And I should say a lot of this work has been done within Team eDynamic, working
very closely with Jens Lubbert is in the audience, but also Vinit and colleagues
who've developed the tools, Amplicon Architect and so on, that have allowed us to
apply those to the whole genome data.
So here we're looking at both the primary tumors, but also the metastatic
tumors. And at a glance, forget ecDNA, but at a glance, if
you look at these amplifications, these high copy number focal
events, you can see, and it was mentioned in the previous two talks,
these oncogenic alterations on the focal applications, these
oncogenic peaks, which are really, I've said suggestive, but
we know that they most likely represent extrachromosomal DNA.
And you can see I've not listed them, but these are your typical
culprits when it comes to oncogenic drivers of tumorigenesis.
And this may not seem like a significant number.
We've applied a very stringent tool, guided by Jens and
colleagues, to really confidently say when you look at the primary tumor
and then longitudinally the metastases, how confident are you
computationally that we are identifying ecDNA?
Well, in about 20% of the cohort here, we're identifying ecDNA,
and this encompasses 37 distinct
ecDNA in about 27 patients. This is not far off from what we saw in
the 14,000, 15,000 Genomics England data set when you look at the
subset of lung cancers. And on the far right, you see
the plot. Paul introduced this paper where we see that lung squamous cell
carcinoma typically harbors a greater burden of ecDNA, and we see that
same association and roughly proportion
in our cohort here. I don't think that's surprising.
We often see karyotype wise that these lung
squamous cell carcinomas are associated with quite significant copy
number alteration in terms of burden, but also complexity of structural variants.
We see that the majority of our ecDNA, unsurprisingly,
will at least contain one oncogene.
In some patients, we can see somewhere up to three, in some, four
oncogenes. There's no real pattern to say
thatThese top oncogenes are the ones that occur most frequently.
You see, again, just real heterogeneity, and unsurprisingly, that
where there is an oncogene on the ecDNA, it's associated with a high copy number
compared to the ecDNA that do not have any oncogenes on them.
I've called them non-oncogenic genes.
But what I think is interesting is that there's comparable copy number
values when you look at ecDNA with an oncogene and ecDNA with no annotated
genes, which really speaks to what Paul mentioned earlier, these
genomic enhancers or genomic promoters.
We've got good evidence to suggest that that's what we are seeing amplified on
those ecDNA.
We're also obviously interested, Paul mentioned the genomics dataset, there's
evidence that where ecDNA is detected, that's associated with immune evasion
or escape. Unsurprisingly, these patients have worse clinical
outcomes. One would hypothesize that they're unlikely to respond or
have mechanisms of immune escape that facilitate relapse and drug resistance.
We too see that the ecDNA often have
immune-related genes that have
significant pathway enrichment, for example, for HLA antigen
presentation,
and that they often are co-amplified with oncogenes.
Again, no specific cohort, perhaps a recurrent pattern.
Perhaps the cohort size is limiting, but we just see this heterogeneity, and
we certainly see the presence of co-amplification.
We also can qualify the ecDNA in terms of what do they originate
from? Is it one chromosome? Is it a multitude of chromosomes?
Well, the majority are derived from one chromosome, what we term
unichromosomal.
And often where we see that there's that co-amplification of a known
oncogene and a putative immune-related
gene, that it's within the genome, this genomic physical
proximity, that potentially facilitates that, often
unichromosomal when we see. But it's not always the case.
Here's another example of a multi-chromosomal ecDNA, different
chromosomes, quite distal genomically, and yet they're able to form
this single ecDNA.
Well, what about the spatial distribution of ecDNA in the context of metastatic
disease? Well, the majority of the ecDNA are present in
all tumor regions, again, suggesting that they're truncal.
They play a role early on in tumorigenesis.
They almost always have to contain an oncogene, at least in this cohort, if we
see that you identify an ecDNA in all regions of
the primary tumor.
And again, we can see that if there's an ecDNA that's
truncal, often these have higher copy number alterations.
You can look at, again, structural features of ecDNA, whether it's the complexity,
the size, it might be the number that you identify.
Again, there's variation across this metastatic cohort and
primary metastatic tumors combined.
It varies, and it varies according to copy number, as one would expect.
This is a case-- I've got a few case studies.
I hope I have time, yes, just over five minutes, that I think really speak to
the value of the longitudinal nature of studies like TRACERx and
Peace, where you can go really deep into the clinical annotation and trying
to understand the disease course of the patient, but also from the
perspective of the primary tumor.
So here's a male patient, 67 years old, ex-smoker,
significant number of pack years.
Stage III A, but still operable, at the borderline of being
offered curative intent surgery.
We sequenced three primary tumors, and these are the circus plots.
So you can see when you
look at these different regions, there's evidence of
hyperamplification that's focal, rearrangements in the primary
non-small cell lung cancer. The three primary tumors from the patient.
And here, this is including the surgical lymph nodes.
Actually, we sequenced five samples from the patient, but lymph nodes are, of
course, even at surgery, the first port of call site of metastatic disease.
If you look back, it looks as if almost there's some sort of,
dare I say, evolution, or the complexity of these rearrangements are
increasing as you move towards the lymph node
metastases. This is using the output from Amplicon Architect.
On the bottom right-hand side, you can see you get this sense of complexity, low
versus high. But visually, you can depict the fragments and the
composition of these ecDNA. So in the left-hand side, you see region
one,
then there's region three, and then there's region two. The numbering is arbitrary.
But you get this sense that as if you go from region one to region
three to region two, this is becoming highly more
complex in terms of the nature of the structural variant.
And on the right-hand side, these are the two lymphatic node
samples. So region one doesn't call that as an ecDNA according to
our computational tools. But you could guess that it's the beginnings
of or the origin of. Now, it's not a non-cancerous cell.
Thinking back to one of the questions,
Paul said, "The genome is huge. There may be certain events that perhaps predispose
or may occur and then go on to transition to some sort of
overt definitive ecDNA." And here again, as I say,
we're inferring that potentially there's some chromosomal rearrangement, and then
has the ability to evolve and turn into a overt ecDNA.
This is the phylogenetic evolutionary tree of this patient.
And again, I think it's interesting.
We don't know, but we think that that one cluster
of
subclones that then go on to disseminate and seed the
lymphatic nodal metastases probably were harboring those
ecDNA,
that we then see become significantly more obvious on the Amplicon Architect
output.
So this is the cohort, the autopsy cohort, where you can see just at a glance,
you move towards heterogeneous and more ubiquitous
or common ecDNA across different regions as you sample
more and more metastases. And if you look at the
33-patient cohort in which this is over 150
samples combined, if you look at ecDNA in the primary tumor only and
ecDNA in the metastases, it's not significant.
But you can see there seems to be
at least a greater proportion of patients who have ecDNA detected in the
metastases as opposed to the primary tumor alone.
This is as close as we can get currently.
Now we're moving into the field of single-cell sequencing.
We're trying to understand there are tools out there from our labs, ALPACER and
CONIFER, that give you clonal resolution of evolutionary phylogenetics
from a copy number and hopefully structural variant perspective.So we're beginning
to now say, what is truly truncal, what is truly branch?
And I mentioned earlier when we were looking at structural variants, these
persistent structural variants that you see in the primary tumor in the metastases.
So another really interesting case, at least in my mind, overall, when you
look at the ecDNA size, structure, and complexity between primary
metastases, it's quite stable. This one outlier in the top
right-hand side was quite interesting to us.
We see this eightfold increase from a primary in isolation to
then the transition to metastatic disease.
I've termed it a persistent ecDNA.
So here's another patient, female, again, active, current smoker with
squamous cell who did not warrant any adjuvant treatment after surgery.
Well, we don't identify any oncogenes, but we can see,
a bona fide ecDNA that harbors this enhancer region.
There's one paper in the literature that
says it's been previously linked in pre-clinical models to make transcription, and
you can look at this in the genome, and you see this.
So the patient undergoes a progression biopsy, and you identify that
same enhancer region in the peritoneal metastases.
And at autopsy, as if clonally, you identify
throughout all the mets, all the different anatomical sites, that same enhancer
region at these high, significantly increased copy number
alterations. Now, this patient only had one primary tumor sequenced
region. And we're looking at the other tumor regions because I wonder, it'd be
very interesting if we see any evidence that this ecDNA, albeit
non-oncogenic, somehow facilitated an evolutionary selection pressure
that meant, again, dare I say, some sort of clonal
sweep or something that meant at autopsy and metastases, it was
present throughout.
Some of the other work we've been doing through the autopsy program and trying to
understand clinically this aggressive phenotype of lung
cancer is looking at intra versus extra-thoracic metastases.
And we've recently published that when you look at the primary tumor sub
clones, you can see those clones that are genomically
doubled, very chromosomally unstable, do the disseminating,
as opposed to those primary tumors in which you still see clones that are not
chromosomally unstable. So we see this evidence that chromosomal instability
drives metastatic dissemination outside of the lungs.
We know, as I said, that's worse outcome, worse comorbidities.
Now, we don't see this in our cohort, but we're beginning to ask these sorts of
questions. Well, do we then see any evidence that ecDNA dictates
the aggressive clinical phenotypes?
Can it play a role in which clones metastasize and where they metastasize to?
And in the last few slides, really, I just want to talk about, again, the clinical
phenotyping. We're beginning to ask questions around can we see any correlative
evidence that ecDNA drives resistance to specific cancer
therapies?
And I know this is
a detailed slide, but really, I just want to visually depict on the right-hand side
the wealth of data we can obtain from the thousands of longitudinal
CT chest, abdomen, pelvis scans that these patients undergo.
And we're beginning to look at differential response.
Can we see metastases where we detect ecDNA and where we don't?
And do we see that that somehow impacts whether they're progressive or regressive
on treatment?
And here we can get a proxy of the total burden of disease.
We can look at the volumetric growth rates of metastases.
This is work led by Wing in my lab, where we're able to look at
150 primary tumors and then look at the
metastatic disease longitudinally and identify that there are patients in whom
in the
third tertile here, the faster-growing tumors, they're transcriptionally
upregulated for proliferation, immune escape.
They fare worse in terms of overall survival, and their tumors grow faster.
And this has not been done before on a lesion by lesion metastatic level.
And we ask the question, well, is there any chance that ecDNA is
enriched in the third tertile, most rapidly progressive tumors?
It's not significant. We're expanding this cohort because this is only 40 or so
patients. But you get the sense that perhaps if you harbor an
ecDNA and it selects for something that
facilitates proliferation and tumor progression, you may very well also see on
imaging that your metastases are growing faster.
Final case study. So here's a patient, ex-smoker, lung adenocarcinoma.
She was given adjuvant treatment.
She was treated with three lines of EGFR inhibition,
tyrosine kinase inhibitors. So she undergoes surgery, we obtain the
primary tumor, and the whole genome sequencing data
demonstrates that an ecDNA
containing ERBB2 is detected not in the primary tumor,
but at first progression, and then in all the metastases at
autopsy, suggesting that potentially it's been selected for and is
driving resistance. Now on the right-hand plot, you get a sense from the imaging
data. All the metastatic tumors we sequenced at
autopsy had that ecDNA,
and they were all rapidly progressing and not
responding to second and third line EGFR inhibition.
And we're now beginning to also sequence the lines that you see in gray because
they were responding at some point, and we wonder if they perhaps didn't
have that ecDNA in them. So it gives you a sense of how, again, ecDNA
detection and integrating with clinical data gives you some insight to mechanisms
of resistance. So I'm really just going to summarize one particular point.
We know the poor prognostic relevance of ecDNA.
We and others have shown this. The genomics England dataset was
very informative in a pan-cancer setting, as Vineet said, even when
you compare it to patients with known amplifications.
But how do we make the diagnosis so that it can guide risk
stratification, and treatment in patients?
And so in team E-Dynamic this year and next year, and even in years
more recent, we've really been trying to think of how can we develop
diagnostic utility using these data, all the computational tools, and
all the breadth of preclinical data that we've done, preclinical
work. And currently, the focus is very much so on how we can use circulating
tumor DNA, be it tumor-informed or agnostic approaches.
So this might be a non-invasive tool that we could implement as a
screening tool, even potentially in our patients that might tell us they've got
worse outcomes, worse prognosis, possibly likely to develop
resistance to certain therapies, and might we
intervene.So I thank eDynamic team
also here.
And because I was the last one, I'm going to make this pitch.
We in team eDynamic were very fortunate last year, led by
Howard and others, and supported by the Cancer Grand Challenge team, to run the
first clinical conference on eDynamic, ecDNA.
And here this year, we're very fortunate to be part of also the second Cancer
Grand Challenge conference looking at cancer and the host.
So please do look into this and let us know if you're interested, and come and
visit us in London. Right. I'm going to stop there because I might be over time,
Paul, I can't tell. But I thank you all. I'm happy to take questions.
Okay.
The foundation of this study is about using graphing
model-based inference of the NGS.
Did you isolate the E chromatin and the physical
clone, the ecDNA sequence, are testably functional
rather than this observation study to model this causality?
I can thank you for the question, but I'm afraid, like the speakers before, I
couldn't hear. Could you, Paul?
Could you sequence ecDNA?
Yeah, just wondering, the sequence ecDNA is about
using the graphing model-based bioinfo analysis.
So just wondering, did you isolate the E chromatin
or clone the whole sequence and model the functioning of this
ecDNA rather than this observational study?
Yes.
I don't think it is causal.
I think I partially understood, but the answer is no, we haven't specifically
sequenced it. I'm hoping that with the single cell and single cell
ATAC and DLP plus and these other methods, again, albeit
we won't have the resolution of actually sequencing the ecDNA itself in the
human samples, but I hope it will tell us a little bit more.
And you mentioned the chromatin and so on, perhaps the single-cell ATAC would help.
Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
The program chairs probably should.
That was a tour de force, Miriam. Thank you. That was brilliant.
So I apologize, but as programming chair,
we have to stay absolutely on time.
So the speakers will stick around to answer
questions. I hope this session has gotten a few things across.
The power of learning from patients, integrating with biological
systems, and developing tools and sharing data to lower the barrier
of entries to colleagues in the field.
We hope that's a microcosm of how we all work together in the future, and thank you
very much.